esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas es
café o el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
difusor público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a las dos y cuarto por las redes
sociales en internet
esta emisión también se encuentra
disponible en nuestro sitio era el cnt
puntos se a este programa es un espacio
dedicado a compartir los mensajes
nuestro correo electrónico es amlat
en el cine nuestro correo regular radio
canadá internacional apartado postal
6000 montear canadá el código postal h
13 3 a 8 y hoy tenemos una mesa llena de
invitados así que vamos a empezar por la
ni por la siniestra las y nietas 25 de
mensaje
paloma martínez martín movilla y quienes
hablaron a valencia en la versión radio
de este programa disponible en nuestro
sitio en ese punto o sea les
presentaremos al músico canadiense que
vibrar en tren ha nacido en toronto su
nombre artístico skyros y del
escucharemos a tres temas musicales bien
entonces empezamos está este trabajo hoy
presentando justamente bueno empezamos
previamente con las noticias que les
hayan llamado la atención por lo por lo
extrañas o sorprendentes a leonardo no
no no nada nada especial la desgracia sí
sí yo sí tengo una una noticia que me
llamó la atención y desde la canadiense
donadora donante de sangre más vieja de
canadá
ella tiene 95 años donante más vieja de
mayor edad ya tiene 95 años y todavía
sigue donando sangre una persona grande
entonces ella hizo su primera donación
de sangre en 1947 la señora
de entonces a cada 56 días acceda a una
donación de sangre y bueno en total ha
dado un solo estado solo aquí y ahora o
no se dice en cuanto en un momento dado
la sociedad de sangre de canadá
tenía una regla que le prohibía seguir
donando sangre y entonces ella se iba a
donar sangre en estados unidos eeuu 270
veces no creo que ella cobraba por eso
pero después entonces la sociedad de
sangre de canadá revisó esa restricción
en el 2005 y ella volvió nuevamente a
donar sangre en canadá eso es bueno para
la salud donar sangre
acabó su película en mariachi vendiendo
su sangre pero hay una realidad en
algunos países sucede en américa latina
por ejemplo cuando una persona se va a
operar tiene que buscar donantes de
sangre que son obligatorios reunirlos
para poder ser operados en términos o
adjetivos calificativos para es terrible
de salud le llamamos viejas viñas que
dan buena producción
[Aplausos]
hablando de esa entonces susana ochoa
baby schumi de fue profesora de español
en guanajuato méxico enseñaba
estudiantes provenientes de estados
unidos canadá y otros países y tras
aprender el francés usted se inscribe en
la academia de hotelería de charleroi
y la tenemos aquí está uno dos tres
cuatro cinco hermosas botellas de vino
deliciosas también cerradas entonces
aunque antes de entrar al tema del vino
con susana el paloma alguna algo que se
llama la atención esta semana pues tanto
como llamarme la atención no pero es
decir me interesó me interesó la llegada
de miguel díaz canel
la cuba a la presidencia cubana más de
60 años con un con un castro han
cambiado completamente don que ahora
ahora estamos con este nuevo presidente
en cuba entonces me llamó la atención en
ese sentido porque es una es un cambio
en esa isla caribeña sino aquí en canadá
pues usted introduce estuvo paseando por
europa los problemas internos lo
persiguieron a europa y entonces ese es
otro tema que estuvo en los medios toda
la semana y tú
por supuesto de uno de los temas de la
semana sigue siendo el tema que nosotros
trabajamos la semana pasada en la
emisión de televisión en la transmisión
de investigación el tema de los
migrantes siguen llegando migrantes esta
semana estuve en la frontera por ejemplo
grabando para este mismo tema y me llamó
mucho la atención entre 6 de la mañana y
7 de la mañana el camino por donde
entran más seguido los inmigrantes para
no atravesar la frontera digamos los
puestos de control oficiales legales
llegaron 30 personas en menos de una
hora y lo que viene va a ser bastante
complejo para canadá porque precisamente
en ese documental quisimos nosotros la
gente está subiendo y vienes a canadá el
sueño canadiense está de moda y yo mismo
que hice ese reportaje por todas las
américas me sorprendí cuando llegué a
ronson road porque 30 personas en una
hora entre 6 y 7 de la mañana que no es
la mejor hora y haciendo frío implica
que en los próximos días la cantidad de
gente que va a llegar la que nosotros
nos encontramos en el camino de amantes
americanos calarse subiendo hacia canadá
en todos los países de las américas y
ahora con el mejor calor está llegando
muchísima gente y la segunda noticia que
me impactó que ha pasado un poco bajo el
radar en los últimos tres días de lo que
está pasando en nicaragua y poca gente
habla de eso en nicaragua hay
manifestaciones hay protestas van tres
personas muertas en el momento en que se
está haciendo esta emisión ahí hay un
aumento rápidamente se resume en una
decisión gubernamental de por decreto de
ordenar una especie de una especie de
impuesto sobre las pensiones de los
retirados del 5% y un aumento de las
tasas de cotización hasta el 22
para los empresarios y hasta el 7% para
el trabajador eficiente daniel ortega
como pensó que el congreso no se debe
aprobar lo hizo por decreto que ayudó a
manifestaciones de personas de la
tercera edad personas mayores antier
hubo heridos antes ellos salieron los
hijos con los papás y hoy salían los
nietos con los papás y los hijos y los
abuelos un poco como argentina sí pero
la situación se ha ido complicando el es
fácil para resumir el rojo y me disculpo
por lo largo que es la primera vez desde
que ortega está en el poder que hay
manifestaciones en diferentes puntos de
managua donde usted reúne más de 500
personas en cada manifestación antes las
manifestaciones no sobrepasaban las 20
30 40 personas en un solo sitio se ha
cerrado canales de televisión están
atacando a la prensa
los movimientos andinistas juveniles
están golpeando a los grupos de protesta
carios entonces me llamó mucho la
atención porque está pasando
desapercibida la noticia a pesar de que
es una noticia importante y para mí lo
que está con esta semana fue justamente
ayer en la tarde el premio nobel de la
paz adolfo pérez esquivel fue a visitar
con junto al nord voz al presidente al
ex presidente de brasil lula da silva y
la respuesta de las autoridades fue
justamente bloquear un derecho básico un
derecho fundamental y lo que decía pérez
esquivel es que lo que ha pasado en
brasil ha sido un golpe de estado contra
dilma rousseff y que ahora está
cleptocracia que controla brasil se da
el lujo de negarle a una persona a la
que no se le ha probado nada concreto y
una vendetta política en brasil para
impedir justamente que lula sea llegar
de nuevo a la presidencia entonces es la
muestra pone en escena justamente ésta
el peso que tienen estas cúpulas
staccato crash ya en brasil donde el 40
por ciento de los miembros del
parlamento están involucrados se prevén
en casos de corrupción entonces son más
pues yo no me sancionó no entra en
detalles pero hay una cosa que están
surgiendo se está debatiendo el tema de
brasil en méxico se está debatiendo el
tema de brasil en otros países la razón
es simple lo que sucedió con lula da
silva demuestra que cualquiera puede
mañana llegar y decir yo le regalé un
apartamento a ruffo confort no lo toma
jamás en posesión nunca lo recibe jamás
lo habita jamás tiene un documento que
lo diga pero la sola declaración de la
persona lleva a la condena oa la captura
de otra hoy está pasando en méxico se
está empezando a hacer acusaciones
parecidas contra lo que sobra de lópez
obrador y está pasando también en
colombia donde hay campañas electorales
y el tema es delicado no es sólo brasil
la pregunta que se hace mucha gente es
suficiente acusar a una persona a pesar
de que no hay ninguna prueba de fondo y
porque la persona que la acusa ha hecho
otros aportes a la justicia que sí era
en realidad para ponerlo en la cárcel el
tema va más allá
por qué
en nuestro amigo martín le regaló un
departamento rufino a mí
ese tipo de apartamento yo puedo ganar
mucho porque son virtuales no lo voy a
aceptar no lo voy a usar pero también yo
creo que es justamente y esto es muy
interesante porque viendo además esto si
se añade lo que está pasando en europa
con regímenes como el de hungría por
ejemplo lo estamos frente a una profunda
crisis de la democracia y la verdad
funciona alguna vez la democracia
pregunta capciosa diría yo podemos
responder a esa pregunta nos perdemos el
filósofo para entrar en filosofía
profunda tomaban vino y nada porque eran
todos ricos
[Risas]
no que no que grave el problema lleva
ansiedad
los trabajo y porque los escogió que
bueno para empezar muchas gracias por la
invitación y yo traje vinos chilenos si
a mí me gustan mucho los vinos chilenos
argentinos españoles siempre mis mis
raíces
me atraen mexicanos sí y también ya ya
comenzaron bien fuertes sobre todo en el
centro aguascalientes guanajuato
querétaro el water
por mi lado sepa de dónde
bueno no hay algunas que vienen directo
de francia
lo que lo que conocemos más es en la
california
pero no el centro el barrio está
comenzando a servirnos bien bien
[Risas]
con mucho cuerpo y bien robustos y bueno
si escogí los vinos chilenos porque me
gustaría hablarles un poquito de la bio
era en chile utilizamos mucho lo que es
la cultura bio y biodinámica hay mucha
cultura orgánica para hacerlos los vinos
son muy bien apreciados aquí en quebec
en canadá y bueno sabemos que la
filoxera llegó a francia alrededor 1860
63 no me equivoco arrasó con los viñedos
franceses toda europa américa
pasó también por áfrica y sus tours en
australia la viña americana resistió se
hizo un injerto de viña americana con la
europea y entonces se empezó a replantar
en europa sin embargo mientras que la
americana resistía a la chilena no le
pasó nada porque son viñas bien sanas
bien resistentes porque la filoxera no
lo tocó no lo sabemos pero sabemos que
no les tocó entonces si no se hubiera
encontrado la solución del injerto con
la con la viña americana chilenos
hubiera salvado la vida y no solamente
eso también había una una variedad de
uva en la carmen era que se pensaba esté
desaparecida y se reencontró en chile
entonces el carménère es casi casi el
símbolo en uvas de chilenas
y te van a encantar
aquí hay un orgánico que como vemos la
etiqueta conosur
muy bueno muy bueno y la casa es muy
responsable en el sentido que cuida
mucho la naturaleza cuidan mucho la
naturaleza son muy orgánicos e incluso
la etiqueta si vemos la etiqueta donde
la ponen negras y la verdad
muy bueno calidad precio calidad placer
muy importante esa relación
es excelente vino es muy agradable si a
después una asamblea y cabernet
sauvignon carmenere ishida bueno vamos a
hacer como santo tomás hay que poner el
dedo en la herida para ver si
efectivamente sí sí sí la lengua en la
herida porque si no vamos a acatar y
tengo un collar collar de la casa
emiliana
que trabaja en bio dinámica
la biodinámica que además de utilizar la
cultura vía orgánica razonable es
responsable por el medio ambiente
incluye el cosmos el universo las fases
lunares
es bien interesante sí sí sí es bien
interesante te va a encantar con mucho
cuerpo las estrellas
diciendo no es esotérico es relacionado
con los movimientos de la célula ya
desastrosos y con el universo los
esotéricos van a venir después los
pueblos indígenas en gran parte todo lo
que hacía sobre todo con las bebidas que
sacaban de las frutas lo hacían teniendo
en cuenta efectivamente los movimientos
que conocían de sol y luna y las
temporadas que conocían de lluvia
se fundamentaban en eso en la calidad
del fruto para el frente la fermentación
también sí claro
viaje los mayas los aztecas los egipcios
los incas
como serios pueblos indígenas en todo
este continente
era muy sabio entonces aquí en collar
estamos utilizando la vía dinámica y la
enóloga es una chica guapísima además yo
creo que tiene 25 o 30 años
de verdad ahorita la ola de enólogos y
productor son bien jóvenes y todos están
bien de acuerdo o sea aquí en américa o
en francia lo que llamamos viejo mundo
un nuevo mundo en su mayoría son jóvenes
y todos tienen la misma idea fórmula y
mentalidad de cuidar el medio ambiente y
ser responsables de lo usa todo lo más
lo máximo orgánico cosa que es muy
productivo para el consumidor porque
también se ocupan de nuestra salud
recomienda vía biodinámica porque ya
cuando empezamos a subir de nivel
yo les recomiendo
4 es una casa que nació en 1993 4 porque
son cuatro tipos de uva cabernet
sauvignon syrah carménère en malbec es
una combinación es una combinación de
uvas es lo vamos a encontrar con más
cuerpo más robusto los taninos más
presentes
y también les me gustaría proponerles el
1865 porque fue el año en que nació en
la casa vinícola por eso se llama así es
un cabernet sauvignon y lo que
encontramos en chile como uvas rojas es
cabernet sauvignon merlot malbec syrah y
nuestro este emblema que es el carmen y
en blanco que sauvignon blanc que
también se conoce como fume blanc y
chardonnay ese millón y el guión y ese
millón es bien interesante porque nos va
a dar sobre todos los vinos licorosos
los dulces los que vamos a tomar para
finalizar la cena o con un queso fuerte
como los busca que son más o menos más o
menos y nos iremos en ese rango tenemos
mensajes pablo y si ruffo si rojo
tenemos aquí entre otros un mensaje de
guild en abril que es nuestra amiga de
nueva brunswick ella nos dice hola
todos desde guanajuato
y dice me falta una semana de clases
antes de regresar acá pelé que es su
pueblo donde viven new brunswick que no
tengo tantas ganas de salir ya que
quiero seguir estudiando pero así es
ella está estudiando en español
4 bueno aquí hay alguien que conoce tu
escuela y milagros del castillo culto
dice convino todo es mejor si
confirmamos mientras se prepara ese vino
pues qué tal si vamos a dar una vuelta a
los mensajes que tenemos nuestros amigos
oyentes sí sí yo tengo aquí hay un
mensaje de paloma
[Risas]
exactamente recientemente sobre el tema
de sobre el tema que tratamos en nuestro
sitio internet una red de delincuentes
colombianos en la mira de la policía en
canadá y édgar ramírez dice qué
vergüenza qué horror que el que dolor
qué pena cómo es posible que existan
colombianos viviendo en canadá y que
cometan estar estas barbaridades un país
tan maravilloso que nos abre las puertas
nos brinda apoyo y donde tenemos tantas
oportunidades de superarnos no solamente
nuestros hijos sino no es nosotros
mismos ese tipo de gente no entiendo
cómo puede entrar a canadá porque la
verdad es difícil llenar y conseguir
toda la documentación para que no se
acepten me siento con vergüenza y
verdaderamente apenado pero en nuestro
país y aquí en canadá somos más las
personas buenas y pocos los delincuentes
dice édgar ramírez sobre una red de
delincuentes colombianos en la mira de
la policía en canadá es eso la noticia
que surgió de efectivamente una banda de
ladrones colombianos sería bueno si
sería muy bueno que la gente también
porque nos hacen que armar a todos
inmigrantes sería bueno que la gente
porque además curiosamente en este caso
del que se habla allí mucha gente sabía
quiénes eran y nadie los denuncia hasta
que lo escogió la policía que sería
bueno que la gente también los denuncie
para que sigan las investigaciones
raquel cervantes se escribe y dice la
visión de la política mexicana de a qué
arma es objetiva por lo que no es del
agrado de quienes han abusado del poder
el costo de
el remedio y si es efectivo me interesa
mucho este tema porque mi pareja tiene
diabetes y está desesperado por
encontrar una cura sufrir de aco phil
sufrir la cfe no o tinnitus causas y
tratamientos ricardo lópez dice el
acúfeno afecta a la vista el equilibrio
frontal la manera de pararse el vértigo
o las distancias y solidaridad
de canadian bomberos luís nigerina
romero dice hola amigos deseo saber qué
se requiere para que ayuden a un cuartel
de bomberos acá en méxico con donativos
ya que no cuentan con los recursos
materiales para poder atender una
emergencia y el gobierno no nos apoya
estoy a sus órdenes que este canal que
median bomberos es una organización
aquí canadiense que así bueno es lo que
está escrito acá de canadian bomberos
así
se presta para confusiones porque en
algunos países latinoamericanos el
bomberos el de la bomba de gasolina
el bombero
[Risas]
es neutro y género sobre el tema de
bloqueado en vísperas de la elección
whatsapp nuevamente accesible en guinea
ecuatorial ricardo ricardo ripoll
escribe dejen de mentir nunca estuvo
censurado
y el tema canadá y su plan de
inmigración 2018 valentina dice hola
buen día
quisiera saber cuáles son los pasos para
trabajar y vivir en canadá a mi esposo y
mi hijo de tres años para todos los que
tengan preguntas sobre el tema el
migratorio dirigirse a la página de la
embajada canadiense en su respectivo
país oa la página
canadá punto sea www de canadá punto o
sea que es el ministerio de la migración
de canadá y encuentran todas las
respuestas a todo
las preguntas en todas las lenguas tengo
otro mensaje acá de las sobre el tema
las colombianas de gerardo ferro rojas
dicen los colombia perdón las mexicanas
las colombianas dice muy acertado su
comentario este escritor no ve la
realidad de colombia solo hace una
apología al comunismo sin importarle la
impunidad que santos le dio a las farc y
aún siguen delinquiendo
casos santrich y hoy detenido por
narcotráfico dice albeiro sobre el tema
de las colombianas de gerardo ferro
rojas bien entonces llegó el momento de
degustar de degustar y entonces como
como se te gusta a ver bueno vamos a
degustar en tres etapas en la primera
para mí siempre lo inmediatamente como
abro la botella
me voy rápidamente para tenerlo los
aromas sintió que usted
el corcho sí sí sí que esté en salud
insalud sí porque si está oxidado o si
tiene un gran defecto al detectar que el
corcho entonces no se puede permitir en
irresponsabilidad sobre todo esté en el
restaurante como sommelier o en el
servicio pues es mi responsabilidad
darle la calidad al cliente no le voy a
dar un vino oxidado o sea que podríamos
dudar si la persona que nos recomienda
el vino no huele el corcho en principio
por protocolo debería hacer lo que
debería hacerlo y cuando él viene
oxidado se detecta rápido es solamente
no nos va a asegurar 100% nos va a dar
algunas señales si lo vamos a saber bien
en la copa y al gusto entonces vamos a
comenzar por lo visual vemos que es un
vino que tiene un color así muy muy vivo
fondo púrpura de semana santa un púrpura
de semana santa eso es bueno es el
collar de valle de colchagua 2013 hace
cinco años que está aquí es una asamblea
que será carmen armen o cabernet
sauvignon y malbec y petit verdot es un
buen cóctel entonces bueno
lo visual nos va a dar una idea más o
menos del grado de una idea de los
grados de alcohol vemos las lágrimas
cómo se ven por la velocidad que
contiene el vino cuando la lágrima cabe
si cae lento si
o rápido tiene inclinar la copa hacia
delante
al devolver la nube la velocidad si baja
rápidamente que significa bueno es el
grado de alcohol que es más
porque estamos degustando tratando casi
casi hasta entonces yo calculo que es
más o menos 14 verificó sí
[Risas]
5 el error y entonces vemos el profundo
vemos que tiene un buen fondo que nos
indica que todavía está bien joven este
vino profundidad está muy oscuro
no lo vas a poner en algo blanco
algo blanco tiene una profundidad
mediana mediana
visibilidad el fondo blanco la densidad
del color la densidad del color la
densidad de 4 más
no necesariamente porque hay por ejemplo
el barolo y el nebiolo italiano que está
bien bien bien claro sin embargo en boca
está muy fuerte
y transparente y hay un pino lugar de
cálculo
exactamente exactamente pero recordemos
que aquí tenemos una asamblea de muchas
cepas la cira el malbec nos va a dar a
dar sin colores muy profundos violetas
muy bien y después nos vamos bueno a la
nariz
vamos a procurar no agitarlo para sentir
los aromas
bueno vienen recuerdos
al memoria olfativa y bueno podemos
clasificar buenas que tiene una nariz
ligera una nariz mediana la fuerza de
los aromas por ejemplo un área grande
por ejemplo
[Risas]
o bien puede ser que los aromas estén
muy poderosos muy fuertes muy intensos
de la madera
de la madera se sienten todos los frutos
rojos son negras porque me gusta es que
no tiene frescos y hay unos vinos que
tienen ese olor que puede llegar a ser
muy fuerte y a veces a mí personalmente
cuando el olor es muy fuerte a veces no
me dan ganas de probarlo me da la
impresión que la fortaleza del olor
viene acompañada de la fortaleza el
alcohol que es muy agradable la cantidad
no es una cosa que tiene que ver más con
la percepción de cada vino conocerlo
pero me llama la atención que a mí
personalmente cuando yo siento el olor
muy fuerte y siempre me es un vino para
dragones
bueno lo visual visual elección mi vicio
te va a dar un indicio de la cantidad de
la cantidad de alcohol pero también la
temperatura porque si está muy caliente
el vino es verdad a mí me ha pasado que
luego
y solamente voló el alcohol porque está
muy caliente el vino entonces ya tiene
que estar la temperatura de las mesas
durante no en cuba por ejemplo 35 43
nos quedan como 10 minutos
nos vamos a lo que nos gusta nos vamos
diariamente y que somos periodistas
serios así que como dicho no aclare que
oscurece
[Risas]
es bien interesante es un vino como
deseamos hecho me dio dinámica vamos a
sentir evidentemente nuestros frutos
rojos o frescas que habíamos dicho un
poco de especias pero también se siente
puro no se siente azúcar residual se
siente en la uva como si de verdad
mordiera la uva en tentaciones por dios
a mí me gusta cuando la acaban de
depresión a impresionar eso cuando uno
acaba de presionarla agua y está fresca
uno siente ese sabor inmediato así
también para la gente que nos está
escuchando los términos la sensación me
seca que te da en el paladar en las
encías los taninos vienen de la semilla
de la hoja si tú muerdes este la semilla
de la uva o el racimo del agua sientes
como madera sensación antes de continuar
vamos ahí mientras vamos saboreando este
vino
y vamos a hacer brevemente una revista a
los temas de la semana to pablo has
estado explorando está por - esta
propuesta de de que me avisaron
todas las todas las drogas sí
[Risas]
y muy buenos días muy rápidamente rojo
es una propuesta de algunos diputados
liberales federal del partido liberal de
canadá que propone están dicho sea de
paso están ahora reunidos en halifax
nueva escocia en un congreso del partido
en la reunión el congreso comenzó ayer y
va hasta el sábado y algunos diputados
del partido liberal proponen que se
descriminalice en todas las drogas ya
sabemos que aquí en canadá a partir del
primero de julio se va a legalizar el
consumo de marihuana y en principio
debería debería funcionar no entonces
ahora lo que proponen estos diputados
liberales es que se
legal y zinc directamente y sedes
criminalicen sobre todo todas las drogas
y así en ese momento vamos a dejar de
tratar a un drogadicto a alguien que sea
adicto a una droga y que consuma vamos a
dejar de tratarlo como un criminal y se
va a tratar más bien como un enfermo
porque dicen los especialistas que estas
drogas pueden matar a una persona y si
matan porque de hecho hay un número en
el 2000 en el 2006 16 2000 42 mil 458
personas murieron por esta crisis de los
opioides y en el 2017 de enero a
septiembre habían dos 1930 y 23 personas
que habían muerto entonces las drogas
producen causan la muerte y en
consecuencia pues habría que tratarlo
como una como una enfermedad entonces
eso es lo que estos diputados proponen
que se descriminalice y qué
lo que se invierte en la en los procesos
judiciales para encarcelar y luego
llevar ante la justicia a los
drogadictos que se inviertan en la salud
entonces que se traten más bien a los
drogadictos como enfermos y no como
criminales y esto inspirados en la
experiencia en portugal tierra de buen
puerto exacto pero hay verdad que yo
como no tengo tema de apoyo el tema de
pablo en una cosa sst eso no tiene nada
que ver con solamente con canadá quiero
decir más que nada que ver
recordemos hace ya varios años varios ex
presidentes entre ellos el presidente
zedillo de méxico el ex presidente
gaviria de colombia fernando henrique
cardoso de brasil el ex secretario
general de las naciones unidas kofi
annan de el ex primer ministro de
holanda ex primer ministro francés están
con el apoyo de la fundación folk
proponiendo la legalización de las
drogas como única solución y ellos
aseguran que hay un fracaso total de la
guerra policial y militar contra las
drogas es decir llevan varios años en
eso son todos ellos ya una guerra contra
las drogas y todos dicen la hicimos
y estamos convencidos de que esa no es
la sal y la legalización la de screaming
la legalización pero dentro de la
legalización se inscriben varias etapas
entre ellas la primera la
descriminalización del consumo y el
control del estado de la producción de
drogas para poner al consumidor la droga
como un enfermo que es y no como
criminales yo creo yo creo que eso
merece un brindis pero antes de brindar
una explicación de que el que desde otro
vino
digo bueno pero vamos a hacer también
maridaje es probablemente a partir del
primero de julio la marijuana he bueno
estamos degustando ahora el 1865 que es
un cabernet sauvignon 2014 y hace cuatro
años que está
aquí en botella y podemos comparar aquí
es el cuerpo está más robusto los
taninos están más más presentes
hay más sensación de madera la acidez la
acidez no está tan tan marcada que
escuchamos mucho cuando se dice hay un
vino equilibrado un vino vino redondo
redondo un vino
balanceado pero bueno así que entre un
vino rojo es
y alcohol
la acidez pero sobre todo los taninos
nadie tiene que sobresalir más que nadie
tienen que estar igual no se tiene que
sentir en boca más acidez ni más taninos
ni más fruta ni más alcohol estamos en
conversación con susan ochoa vega
sumiller quien nos está justamente
haciendo degustar y enseñándonos
básicamente cómo cómo navegar entre este
estos esos efluvios vegetales que
también hacen a la humanidad
[Risas]
en realidad que es el vino en el fondo
es el vino el tiempo es fácil pero
además de perder el tiempo en la vida el
tiempo simplemente juego de uva
fermentado si las tres botellas crean
sino las abrimos vuelve yoyo grupo con
la que abramos las botellas hoy es que
la próxima semana traigamos col
[Risas]
lo que las lágrimas al principio que es
la primera etapa que me hacía pensar en
el chiste de que bueno primero en el
proceso de la degustación primero son
las lágrimas y después se bebe mientras
que la vida normal
primero se bebe más tarde por medio y ya
que encontré un artículo que dice la
lágrima más densa y de caída lenta nos
va a indicar que el vino es un tuozzo
con cuerpo y el grado alcohólico
generalmente es más importante por el
componente de etanol más abundante en
esa cantidad se tiene más alcohol que el
anterior en el último
[Música]
no vemos las lágrimas
es muy interesante aprender sobre sobre
los vinos porque es al final a veces los
desechamos o no sabemos lo que yo decía
una rato y escuchamos muchas cosas y
entonces es un dolor puede que nos aleje
y resulta que ese olor debería darnos la
idea de continuar de que es bueno y yo
creo que no podemos desperdiciar la
botella
del programa
si no lo ponen lo bate entre comillas lo
revuelve por decantación se oxigena y
gana año de vejez digamos leonardo en 30
segundos cambio y tema propones nuestros
oyentes fin de semana y no otra tipo no
otra historia con facebook y en este
caso es que a pesar de todo lo que está
pasando este último tiempo está
invirtiendo en generar su propio
hardware es decir en intentar está
buscando gente para desarrollar en los
mismos los procesadores para mantener su
empresa en competencia algún mensaje por
el momento no viene entonces bien
entonces que usted ha hecho varias
entrevistas
entonces le agradecemos por justamente
compartir con los con los amantes del
vino en karting que baker pues estos
saberes y estas memorias y pues como
decía vamos a sería genial tener el
tiempo suficiente como para poder
saborear todos y cada uno de estos vinos
pero lo bueno es que nos quedan tres
botellas para la próxima ocasión
entonces alguna próxima semana la
próxima semana no la próxima ocasión
porque eso que a puede llegar en
septiembre a la próxima semana entonces
estamos hablando
genial entonces cuando vuelve de nuevo
[Risas]
de vinos de importación privada que
debería así cierto demandado bien y para
ese momento entonces si tenemos el queso
bien amigos entonces aquí llegamos al
final de este programa que nada en las
américas café va a un brindis por
ustedes gracias por estar con nosotros y
muchas gracias
misma suerte ver con el vaso pasión
[Música]
hasta la próxima un abrazo a todos ya
todas